[Música]
o pessoal votar a obrigava a a
realização por um ter convidado e não se
esquecer o primeiro deixa mais tranqüilo
me deixa mais nervoso mas agora lá como
a catarina dirceu vamos falar sobre
sobre viagens
a polícia forçou muitas coisas mas o
pessoal vamos contar um caso da minha
história e vai falar sobre esta foto eu
escolhi esta falta por aqui não é
claramente o que favorece jamal vai
passar três dias o acerto mesmo querer
conquistar minha vaga e claramente não
nativas e agora vai com vocês podem ver
mas tava estava em viagem estava na
guatemala não nasce da maia que chama
fiscal que é no meio da selva que vocês
plantaram em si mesmo tempo exceto e na
teoria está a viver uma experiência que
sabia que era a única e acho que estava
vendo a minha cara da hungria foi dada a
contar um caso como é que cheguei até
aqui eu tenho que escolher o curso que
sempre tento não sei porque eu nunca
ninguém me obrigou a criar um consenso
tentaram mas não sabe viver em portugal
acho que esse é um fator que faz com que
o pessoal vá para a sociedade também foi
instável mas poderão pagar o continente
tentarem de banho e eu era um aluno
portanto quando estiver o 12º ano
escolher um curso universitário e não
fazer a mínima ideia que estava a fazer
só pressão em cima está já na altura a
mãe não sabia o que queria escolher mais
ou menos a senhora não tinha a mínima
maturidade para entender a decisão
estava tomada e eu acho que não sei se
vocês assim com isto mas como eu acho
que muita gente acontece mesmo com muita
gente tem falado com muitas pessoas
muita gente toma esta decisão de fato é
super importante pela necessidade nos o
homem do futuro melhor um trabalho
melhor
mas eu acho que antes de baixa
intensidade será que você quer fazer e
acho que é isso que falta um cabo e foi
isso que faltou a jogada que eu entrei
na universidade e adorei adorei está na
universidade não sei sinceramente sair
do coronel está aí
os meus amigos aí tava na estrada que
sai das festas era um aluno mas só
quando cheguei ao 5º ano o assunto é
administrado estava a trabalhar esta
gear é preciso em que eu tenho que fazer
é não gostava
e foi engraçado porque aí acho que tive
a oportunidade de entender a decisão
tomada há cinco anos e foi aí que
percebi que tinha sido a pior decisão na
minha vida provavelmente até aquele
momento que foi um caso complicado
porque os meus amigos na universidade
pensavam todos de forma diferente da
minha e eu já sabia o que queria fazer
quando a criança tinha já queriam
publicar e eu não sou de nice e foi
sentir aquela sentimos em frente mas não
vão sentir mesmo no mau sentido
não gostava que eu estava sentindo
completamente perdido e engraçado que na
altura ninguém mais do que eu pensava
era criança viajar e eu não fazia isso
aí porque eu que seria mais ou menos mas
não sabe muito bem porque olha que eu
não tinha nenhuma me próxima terça com
experiência e com a minha idade eu sabia
que ia viajar
tinha a sensação ea esperança que
viajavam pudesse trazer respostas a
estas perguntas que ela tem por que eu
iria fazer vou fazer e me sentia um caso
diferente e nós não era bom é tentar
passar o usuário não está a funcionar
nas suas passagens
então nessa altura em que eu estava
sentindo de frente um carro perdendo
conheci uma associação cap portugal
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar do
conceito de rap e da atração do
português seria tipo no sábado em um ano
a um ano e um ano e principalmente
preparar
acho que a coisa mais importante mas
pode ser humano a viajar para fazer um
estágio para fazer coisas mais pessoais
preparar e trabalhar pra quê para pensar
nos conhecermos para isabel mesmo estou
a pensar um ano para pensar
normalmente é um ex passo é um conceito
que está em muitos países 91 estágio
antes de entrar na universidade
precisamente para não
a decisão errada como fez né e ou então
você pode dar um carro do trabalho
quando os jogos seja naquela altura
quando conheci a seguir esta profissão
em portugal tem o objetivo de promover
este conceito para os jovens como eu não
tomei as cinzas geradas com o tamanho e
na altura foi altamente o exército a
sessão porque eu senti mas não sozinho
sentindo acompanhado ou seja pessoas
como eu não as conheça ainda mas há
pessoas que pensam como eu e aqui pra
mim foi incrível
nessa altura eu conheci tamanho da marca
está aí no público e nós percebemos que
aquilo que nós queremos fazer era viajar
só que só havia um problema real alguns
problemas mas primeiro eu não fazia
idéia de como é que viajava não sabia
nada sobre a já não fazia mesma menina e
depois acho que o maior problema era não
temos ninguém porque eu tinha saído do
rock mick nessa altura não não queria
trabalhar vim aqui me que não estava
também a melhor química tenha arranjado
emprego em uma série pois não haveria
ela tava acabar o mestrado ela
o sargento não tenhamos nenhum mas foi
também uma altura boa porque quando
conheceu a seleção b portugal
eu percebi que eu estava a promover um
concurso pela primeira vez esse ano e
depois a partir deste ano todos os anos
um concurso para dar um bebê a uma ou
duas pessoas e obviamente que vamos
fazer um plano del piero projeto e
depois supostamente no final escolher o
melhor projeto que nós temos o melhor
projeto e ganhamos e portanto vamos
viajar e esta foi a nossa viagem nós já
nos oito meses pelo continente americano
como estamos no brasil embaixo nós temos
o uruguai argentina chile e possuímos
até o méxico méxico - nova york em nova
york vamos pra cá foram oito meses no
continente americano e depois com metal
em portugal também também conta com
viagens por dia mas só de estar aqui
horas a falar sobre esta viagem
foram oito meses muitas coisas
aconteceram jamais tivemos um feriado em
boates e tivemos um feriado por uma
quinta feira contrariado no equador com
crianças um mês numa escola tivemos no
panamá no festival música ajudar a
organizar tivermos nicarágua no móvel
trabalhar quase um mês foi um dos
princípios super dura porque é um país
muito pobre e que todos os dias é um
desafio por exemplo é um dos países mais
desafiantes mas também mais bonitos foi
foi uma experiência intensa foi à
bolívia onde nós passamos o natal pela
primeira vez longe da família não
tínhamos conexão com a internet também
foi até falar com a minha família eu vi
a imagem aos outros aquilo que eu não
consegui falar mais e é um país muito
pobre e engraçado porque foi feira foi
uma das grandes lições que aprendi em
viagem foi na bolívia porque nós não
estava nos imaginam estamos no mercado
entre o quase tudo que as pessoas faziam
chocavam tempo nesse processo não sei lá
enfim coisas assim deste ano mas foi
nessa altura percebemos que não manda
aqui é um mercado com 200 pessoas
nós dois éramos no estado já pensava em
frente e portanto qual é nossa onde
estava a jogar as pessoas nós somos
diferentes numa daquelas suas férias
isso foi uma das lições que a viagem os
trans e podemos falar em casa então é
antes nós com vocês viram aqui nessa
imagem fãs do sul ao norte americana e
que nós não devemos estar sempre mais ou
menos na altura do verão
portanto criamos um consegue nós vamos a
seguir o sol e daí criamos nossas
páginas nem sair a meio facebook essas
coisas são partilhadas em continuar a
partilhar as nossas viagens e chama se
falou sam
esperamos nós antes de cantar então
aquela experiência consegue contar no
início
estou em ficar disse na guatemala no
meio da selva quando eu digo mas ela
mesma da célula tempo para caminhar e
restaurante
em itá tipo olavo do dos tempos tem um
poço com água concluiu se esteja a falar
com os guardas não te contar quando é
que passamos agora a linha de agora
colar é mesmo selva porém nós criamos
irá ficar nós não queremos temos para
esse tipo normal chegar lá com grupo
turistas pelas coisas de vazarem
perguntar foi agora que o parque
arqueológico ficar um tempo 50 e tal
quilómetros quadrados a zona dos tempos
é gigante 32 quilômetros quadrados que
estas não estou agora
mas fora da zona dos tempos na zona do
parque tem um parque de campismo e nós
queremos o parque campismo e ainda
poupar tempo e não tenhamos uma idéia
uma carrinha de uma plataforma tinha
matrícula do por uma gera um casal de
americanos que viajaram por uma tábua
mal e engraçado porque o homem do casal
eu era original da guatemala
só que na altura quando era criança
tinha os pais do que nos estados unidos
porque causa da guerra civil agora é
voltar a ter muitos anos de guerra civil
e eu como sou no contato que nessa
altura quando era miúdo se lembra que
estava tudo uma confusão um incrível
então eu tinha conseguido entrar dentro
da cidade maia onde estou agora deputado
na cidade no meio da selva
durante a noite uma cidade tempo com
três mil anos de história deve ser uma
coisa brutal e as chuvas e há 3 mil anos
de história que teve militar a
descoberta pela estação ninguém saber
que ela existia e enfim eu só pensava
naquilo mesmo eu como fazendo quando
fazia sempre foi falar com as pessoas e
falar com os valores do parque campeões
não siga baixinha e gordinha 5 cataratas
nos olhos mas são todos assim e ela
estava a falar com ele e depois
introduziu o tema então é tão linda
estava lento vencer uma coisa votar em
law não se ponha horas muito vigoroso
vavá muito controlados e puyol estava em
lagoa no mês passado as horas e os com a
minha velha senhora tu tatu era meu
amigo estourada com os guardas
isto quiser pode entrar dentro da cidade
eu venho jogando realmente não sabia
dessa vez a aventurar se restringe à
verificar a aquela mistura temporada
natalina com medo enfim mas é como é
óbvio disse que sim então entretanto
ficou noite
isto é à noite parece que as telas com
quadro da nossa festa fica que eu não há
mesmo pois a iluminação nenhuma está
noite marcelo ficou à ficou noite
chumbar a nossa vida tem uma uma shot
gun problema para seus negócios
então eu ela chegou à bahia para tentar
nós estávamos lá essa senhora
vocês vão quiserem eo povo quiser eu
vendia lá então nós
nós basicamente para campismo aceite um
dos fornos que era a praça principal
tarde e 40 minutos de caminhada para
você ver como aquilo é vizinha de nós
quando quisermos que ponto é que nós
quisermos e fomos para a praça principal
e ficamos a dormir em cima do templo 2
não sei acho que é um caso difícil
descrever essa experiência me acho que
vocês conseguem entender a única coisa
que eu pensava na altura é provavelmente
só acelera o primeiro português eu ia
tomar os primeiros portugueses a
história do miss na noite no meio da
selva numa cidade maia no templo com
dois mil e tal anos
de fato foi uma daquelas experiências
brutais em estágio mesmo é viver o
momento presente a necessidade extrema e
daí aquela cara e foi imensa e voltar de
portugal e eu tenho esta fotografia aqui
desta campanha porque nós rodamos
portugal e voltamos de viagem a portugal
foi sempre assim só não acabou aí acabou
em portugal porque nós
eu desde esse ano traz cinco anos eu eu
juntava os meus amigos nesta que é a
minha casa no meu dia na ugt a gente
tava nova amigos vamos acampar pelas
praias portugal e vamos assim e era
sempre o tipo era um carro um treinador
era eu
isabel brasil deve ficar onde era uma
coisa mais ou menos natural mas enquanto
estava a festa ganha com os meus amigos
finalmente a viagem que eu tinha feito
as princesas que eu fiz e principalmente
esperar esta fiscal deu uma resposta
àquelas perguntas todas que eu tinha no
início que era o que eu ia fazer o que
eu quero fazer não sei nada disso e eu
nem percebi o que eu queria ser que eu
queria fazer
eu queria fazer exatamente aquilo que
estava fazendo naquele momento quero os
meus amigos a fazer preciso nem queria
viver aquilo que eu vivi a viajar e é
engraçado esta arrancada mensagem deus
quer passar é engraçado porque viajar em
seus muitos mas eu acho que aquilo que
nos dá mais é que nos vá conhecer as
nossas raízes aquilo que nós somos
aquilo que nós queremos
e quando eu ia viajar obviamente eu
estou falando fazendo a viagem desafio
não estou falando de pau méxico e
caipirinhas
quer dizer conhecemos não ficando com
seus carrinhos não é fazer ela é tipo ir
aos mercados câmeras comidas apanhar
banha é qualquer cena mas fazer da
viagem
o desafio é engraçado porque viajar
depois nos ajudado a conhecer já nas
próprias viajar na imaginação ea
capacidade de sermos o que nós quisermos
era que a centena que é o momento de ser
aquilo que eu quisesse importantes neste
momento aquilo que eu queria ser eu
mesmo
é eu sou líder viagens trabalho com uma
empresa que chega no skype e organiza
viagens para o pro guatemala e para a
colômbia
eu acho que o meu trabalho agora é fazer
as pessoas que vêm comigo presenciar
esta pureza ea gestora das coisas boas e
as coisas más os seus vãos seus maus as
culturas tudo que é viajar e fazê las a
conhecer as suas próprias risco em si
próprias tal como aconteceu comigo e é
isso que eu tenho para descontar
[Aplausos]
[Música]